this right over here is a self-portrait
that rembrandt made in 1640 and what's
really interesting about it is like
other great artists like leonardo da
vinci and salvador dali and many many
many others
rembrandt really cared about something
called the golden ratio
the golden ratio and i've done whole
videos about it it's this fascinating
fascinating fascinating number that's
usually denoted by
usually donated by the greek letter phi
and if you were to expand it out it's an
irrational number so you could
1.61803 and it just goes on and on and
on and forever but there's some very
neat mathematical properties of phi or
the golden ratio if you start with phi
and if you were to add to that if you
were to add to that or actually let's
start it this way if you were to start
with
1 and add to that 1 over
1 over phi let me write my phi a little
bit better
you add to that 1 over 5 that gives you
5.
so that's kind of a neat thing
now if you were to multiply both sides
of this equation
by phi you get that if you start with
phi and then if you add 1 you get phi
squared so it's the number you add one
you get you get its square these are all
really really neat things it can even be
written as a continued fraction phi
could be rewritten as
1 plus 1 over
one plus one over
one plus one over and we just go like
that forever and ever and ever that also
gives you phi so hopefully this gives
you a little appreciation that this is a
really cool number and not only is it
cool mathematically but it shows up
throughout nature and it's something
that artists have cared about because
they believe that it it helps define
human beauty and we see that rembrandt
really cared about it in this painting
and how can we tell well that's what
we're going to analyze a little bit
through this exercise in this video
we could construct a triangle obviously
these triangles aren't part of his
original painting we superimpose these
but if you were to put a base of a
triangle right where his arm is resting
and then if you were to have the two
sides of the triangle kind of outline
his arms and shoulders and then meet at
the tip right at the top of this arch
you would construct triangle a b d just
like we have here
and then if you were to go to his eyes
and you could imagine human eyes are
what we naturally look at whether we're
looking at a face or a painting of a
face if you look at his eyes and if you
were to draw a line there that's
parallel well that really connects the
eyes and it's parallel to this to the bd
right over here so let's call that
segment pr right over there we'll see
that there's that this that this ratio
the ratio between this smaller triangle
and this larger triangle
involves phi so this is what we know
that what we're being told about this
painting this is quite fascinating the
ratio between the length of segment cd
and bc is 5 1. so you drop an altitude
from this larger triangle this ratio the
ratio of
cd
length of cd to bc that's phi
so clearly rembrandt probably thought
about this
even more we know that pr is parallel to
bd we've actually constructed it that
way so that is going to be parallel to
that right over there
and so this is also and so the next clue
is what tells us that rembrandt really
thought about this the ratio of ac to aq
so ac is the altitude of the larger
triangle the ratio of that to a q which
is the altitude of this top triangle
that ratio is five plus one to one or
you could even say that ratio is phi
plus one so clearly rembrandt thought a
lot about this now using all that
information let's just explore a little
bit let's see if we can come up with an
expression that is the ratio of the area
of triangle abd so the area of the
larger triangle to the area of triangle
apr so that's this that's the smaller
triangle right up here so we want to
find the ratio of the area of the larger
triangle to the area of
area of the smaller triangle and i want
to see if we can do it in terms of phi
if we can come up some with some
expression here that only involves only
involves phi or or or constant numbers
or manipulating phi in some way so i
encourage you to pause the video now and
try to do that
so let's take it step by step what is
the area of a triangle well the area of
any triangle is one half times base
times height so the area of triangle abd
we could write as one half
times our base our base is the length of
segment bd so one half times bd and
what's our height well that's the length
of segment ac
one half times bd maybe i'll do segment
ac well let me do it in the same color
times
the length of segment
a c
now what's the area this is the area of
triangle abd one-half base times height
now what's the area of triangle apr well
it's going to be one-half
times our the length of our base which
is pr
segment pr the length of that
times the height which is the height of
segment aq so the length of segment aq
we could just write it like that times
the length of segment aq so how can we
simplify this a little bit well we could
divide the one-half by the one-half
those two cancel out but what else do we
know
well they gave us the ratio between ac
and aq the ratio of ac to aq
the ratio of ac
to aq right over here is 5 plus one to
five to one or we could just say this is
equal to five or we could say this is
just equal to five plus one so let me
rewrite this let me actually let me
write it this way this is going to be
equal to
so we have the length of segment bd over
the length of segment
pr
and then this part right over here we
can rewrite this is equal to 5 plus 1
over 1. so i'll just write it that way
so times
5 plus 1
over 1. so what's the ratio of bd to pr
so b
d
to p r so the ratio of the base of the
larger triangle to the base of the
smaller triangle
so let's think about it a little bit
what might jump out at you is that the
larger triangle in the smaller triangle
that they are similar triangles they
both obviously
have angle a in common and since pr is
parallel to bd we know that
this angle corresponds to this angle so
these are going to be congruent angles
and we know
we know that this angle
corresponds to this angle right over
here so now we have three corresponding
angles are congruent this is congruent
to itself which is in both triangles
this is congruent to this this is
congruent to that you have three
congruent angles you're dealing with two
similar triangles and what's useful
about similar triangles are the ratio
between corresponding parts
corresponding lengths of the
corresponding parts of the similar
triangles are going to be the same and
they gave us one of those ratios they
gave us the ratio they gave us the ratio
of the altitude of the larger triangle
to the altitude of the smaller triangle
ac to aq is 5 plus 1 to 5. but since
this is true for one as one
corresponding part of the similar
triangles this is true for any
corresponding parts of the similar
triangle that the ratio is going to be 5
plus 1 to 1.
so the ratio of bd the ratio of the base
of the larger triangle to the base of
the smaller one that's also going to be
5 plus 1 over 1. so this is also
this is also going to be phi i could
write this as let me just write it this
way this this could also be rewritten as
5 plus 1 over 1. so what does this
simplify to well we have five plus one
over one times five plus one over one
well we could just you know divide by
one you're not changing the value this
is just going to be equal to and we
deserve a drum roll now this is equal to
phi
plus one
five plus one squared so that was pretty
neat and i encourage you to even think
about this because we already saw that 5
plus 1 is equal to phi squared and
there's all sorts of weird interesting
ways that you can continue to analyze
this